The first rule of Mars life is....
Don't talk about Mars life.
Hi everyone, I'm Ian O'Neill, space producer
for Discovery News and I've commandeered the
DNews video studio to share some news that,
well, kinda flew under everyone's radar.
In case you didn't notice by all the rovers
and satellites we have orbiting Mars, we are
fascinated with the Red Planet.
We can't live there without a spacesuit because
the air is too thin and the planet is bathed
in radiation.
But it's the closest thing we have to Earth
in the whole solar system.
There's been a recent flurry of science results
from NASA's Mars rovers.
These results suggest that not only was Mars
once a very wet world, the water existed in
a liquid state and was pH-neutral, or safe
to drink.
So when you collect all the evidence, it's
not such a stretch of the imagination to think
that basic lifeforms, like single-celled microbes,
once mingled in the Mars rock and soil millions
of years ago.
The next step would be to send a robot (or
even humans) to the surface of Mars to collect
a sample of rock and launch it back to Earth.
That way geologists and astrobiologists can
analyse the samples to look for ancient fossils
of microbes.
But nature is already one step ahead.
Mars, like every planet in the solar system,
is smashed by asteroids and some of the Martian
impacts have been so energetic that chunks
of the Martian crust have been blasted into
space.
After drifting for possibly millions of years,
these rocks may fall to Earth as meteorites.
We know of hundreds of Mars meteorite examples
and these precious commodities have been studied.
This pretty cool concept has led to the hypothesis
of "panspermia," where life may hitch a ride
on meteorites and spread from planet to planet
like highly infectious interplanetary herpes....
but that's a whole other story.
Anyway, back to these new results...
In February, NASA scientists published a paper
discussing tiny tunnels and holes inside a
30 pound Mars meteorite.
They say these structures are similar to "bio-alteration
textures" in glasses found on Earth formed
by terrestrial microorganisms.
They use terms like "biogenic origins" and
"biotic activity" -- but at no point the researchers
mention the word "life."
You'd expect every tabloid paper in the world
to have this splashed across their front pages.
But the news just kinda sailed by.
Other scientists praised NASA researchers
for avoiding speculative comments about finding
signs of life on Mars.
Just because this particular meteorite has
features that may have been created by tiny
Martians doesn't mean that they were.
This is science at its finest.
While this is tantalizing evidence for life
on Mars, more studies are needed.
And probably the only way that we will get
proof is when we can analyze a microbe's DNA,
which is probably good enough reason for humans
to finally set foot on Mars carrying a microscope
and forensics kit.
Are you as excited by this finding as I am?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to DNews for more science videos
every day of the week.